.
>> Tucker: DOUGLAS THINGS ARE
MUCH APPRECIATED.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: ELON MUSK HAS BEEN
OFF A LOT HERE FAMOUSLY SMART WE
PROBABLY UNDERSTAND THAT BUT
WHAT IS IT LIKE TO RUN A DIGITAL
MEDIA PROPERTY THAT'S MAYBE OUT
OF STEP WITH THE HURT?
DAVE PORTNOY HAS ON THAT A LONG
TIME FOR SCHOOL SPORTS ASKING
HIM [LAUGHS]
YOU DON'T WANT POLITICAL SITE
YOU DON'T TO BE CONTROLLED
THEY'VE GONE AFTER YOUR PERSONAL
LIFE, THEY REALLY VEX YOU TRY TO
DESTROY YOU FOR REAL WHAT YOU
THINK ELON MUSK IS IN FOR?
>> WHILE HE IS ONE BIG ADVANTAGE
OVER ME IS NOW IN CONTROL OF
TWITTER HE IS THE ULTIMATE SAY.
ELON SAID SOMETHING WRONG TRUE
TO ME.
IF YOU RUN THIS CORRECTLY 10% ON
EACH SIDE OR TO HATE YOU.
I MUST THINK ABOUT THIS
ELON MUSK BUYING TWITTER.
EVEN COME ON THE SHOW YOU KNOW
TUCKER PEOPLE THING A POLITICAL
ALL THE COMPLAINING IS FROM ONE
SIDE.
SOME FROM THE OTHER.
YOU JUST WANT EVEN PLAYING
FIELD.
A SUBLEASE OF SUMMING ABOUT YOU
WITH THE ABILITY TO RESPOND,
WHAT I FIND HAPPENS IS PEOPLE
THAT I CAN NAME JULIA HAACK
COMES PEOPLE LIKE THIS JUST
THROW SHOTS THAT YOU WHEN YOU
RESPOND TWITTER IF AN ARMY OF
BOTS AND PEOPLE WHO SAY
HARASSMENT, HARASSMENT,
HARASSMENT AND THEY GET YOU
BANNED.
THEY THROW ALL THE ARROWS AND IF
YOU RESPOND ONCE OR DEFEND
YOURSELF YOU GET BANNED AGAIN IN
TROUBLE, I THINK THAT IS
ESSENTIALLY WHISPER THIS ON ON
FOR ELON MUSK BECAUSE HE GOT
MUTED HE SAID HEY, LET'S OPEN
THE PLAYING FIELD EXCHANGE SOME
IDEAS.
I WILL AGAIN WANT TO SING SO
MUCH OF OUR UNTHINKINGLY CLEAR
MOM NO.
BUT IF YOU HAVE AN IDEA OR A
THOUGHT THAT CRITICIZES THE
OTHER SIDE THAT ALLOWS RESPONSE.
BUT THE GOOD NEWS IS HE'S THE
ULTIMATE GUY'S ULTIMATE GANG
STARTS A MILLION TIMES.
I WISH I COULD BE HIM IF YOU
LIKE ME DON'T LIKE WHAT'S GOING
ON I'M SCARED BY OPEN LETTER
RUN.
HE SESAME VERY KEY PIECE HE
PLAYED EARLIER.
IS NOT ABOUT ECONOMICS.
HOW MUCH OF THAT IS TRUE I'M NOT
SURE, BECAUSE EVERYTHING HE
TURNS INTO HIS GOLD.
THE MAJOR THING IS WHATEVER YOU
LOOK, WISE ONE SIDE ALL
COMPLAINING AND THE OTHER SIDE
ISN'T WESTERN MARK THAT TELLS
EVERYTHING.
NEED TO MAKE AN EVEN PLAYING
FIELD THAT'S WHEN ANYBODY WANTS
THE ABILITY TO SPEAK BACK AND
DEBATE POINTS.
>> Tucker: BUT WHAT YOU SAID
IS THE DEFINITION OF FAIRNESS,
IT'S HOW WE CONDUCT SPORTS AND
BUSINESS AT ITS BEST.
WHY IS THAT SUCH A THREAT WHEN
IT TAKES PLACE IN THE MEDIA?
>> I'M THINK THAT THERE IS AN
ILLUSION.
BUT THERE IS NO FAIRNESS GOING
ON.
THERE'S AN ACCOUNT THE BUSINESS
INSIDER, THEY DO TWEET THAT SAID
HOW GREAT IT WAS THAT JEFF BEZOS
IS PAYING THEM BIND
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
NOW THEY DO TWEET THAT SAID THIS
IS THE END OF CIVILIZATION
BECAUSE ELON MUSK IS BUYING
TWITTER.
IT JUST DEPENDS WHAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR BUT THE KEY THING IS
THERE IS NO FAIRNESS, ANYONE IS
PAYING ATTENTION THERE'S NOTHING
FAIR.
THERE'S THE ILLUSION OF FAIRNESS
WITH ME WERE TRYING TO BE FAIR
BUT ANYONE WHO'S PAID AN OUNCE
OF ATTENTION WAS THAT EACH
PLATFORM SPECIFICALLY LEAN
CERTAIN WAYS.
AND THE CRAZIEST THING IS,
INSTAGRAM OR THE FACEBOOK OR
ZUCKERBERG, IF YOU LIKE THAT
SENSOR 10X WITH TWITTER DOES.
I'LL DO IT AND THEY ALL CERTAIN
WAYS.
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH
FAIRNESS BUT YOU'RE AN IDIOT IF
YOU THINK THESE ARE NEUTRAL
PLATFORMS ANYMORE SO INSERT
NEWSPAPERS IN CERTAIN WAYS OR
EVEN NEWS OR CNN.
WE THINK THOSE ARE LOOKING AT
EVERY SUBJECT ON THE MIDDLE
WALL, YOUR HEAD IS IN THE SAND
THE SAME WITH TWITTER.
>> Tucker: ALL YOU CAN ASK FOR
HIS CLARITY AND GIVING OTHER
PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RESPOND ANSWER IS PROMISING.
>> IF YOU LISTEN TO ANYTHING
THAT HE SET OUT DON'T KNOW WHY
ANYONE OWING TO THE SIDE WOULD
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH IT.
THE LEASING HE WANTS IT DEAD
DOWN THE MIDDLE AND HAVE 10% OF
BOTH SIDES TO BE LIKE THIS IS
WRONG, THAT'S HOW HE KNOWS IT'S
GOOD.
EVER HEARD ANYONE POLITICAL BUT
ELON MUSK.
SIMPLE AS IT IS AND AS STUPID AS
IT IS, HE'S NOT GONNA BRING BACK
TRAUMA.
THAT'S A LOT OF AUDIBLE PEOPLE
ARE FREE NOT